[Music]
in alcohol diet news oh because my heart
actually needs it to survive huh
it's more sold its fill the hole in a
soul yeah I caught spirits as far as
submitted by dicks and chicks dicks and
chicks dicks and checks dicks and chicks
like a city from Dickson Tennessee like
Dixie Chicks but oh yeah Dixie Chicks
I was thinking transsexuals Diggs and
chicks a man goes on a beer only diet
for Lent
wait then what happened he's dead is
that when you don't eat meat no you give
up something give something that keeps
no meat on Fridays right yeah so it's
you're like pescetarian on Fridays or
something like that yeah but for Lent
you give up something that is nice to
you that keeps using away from God so
like wait what would we all give up
Wednesday that's part of it yeah that's
the day it starts yes let's say poo ash
on your face on your forehead you know
what's so funny like a lot of people who
do Lent or my friends that did lend they
would give up the most arbitrary [ __ ]
but has nothing to do with them and
their relationship my part I'm gonna
have to give up like tie my shoelaces
the way I want bro like coke I'm gonna
give up coast again I always thought it
was lint
lint yeah kid I'm like why do we got to
do this lint stuff
what's a let worthy sacrifice like your
Coco sex yeah something you love wait
what would y'all give up though I
wouldn't give up so now those Oh me
giving up me was already huge Oh every
Friday I'd be in the middle of eating it
I'm like oh I forgot yeah I would get
along you have to do it for until um
Easter yeah he's 46 oh I thought it was
like a weekend thing I was like oh I'll
get
although like gaming or alcohol or
something you know if you're a burglar
and you stopped robbing for a month
that's like yeah I guess so yeah yeah
yeah cuz then you got a fine job for 40
60 100 else if that helps him helps me
get closer to God I like it when people
that can't even get Lego I'm gonna give
up and the absolute master Batian 446
that's good oh that would be damn near
impossible yeah that's because 46 days
without that is just gonna come out
either way there's gonna be way more car
crashes in the United oh for sure I did
yeah just are rubbing up on things for
no reason he looks like a dope he's from
Ohio and he decided to go in a beer only
diet Cortlandt looks like he would do
that so he's not eating any food he is
drinking water and black coffee with no
sugar and stuff but other than that and
he's already in like one weekend he lost
15 pounds no [ __ ] like what so you plan
on just being drunk the whole time he's
like no I just hate so for him he'd
dream arming himself in like pretty much
he's fasting so he's doing this based on
months so monks did this back in 1600s
they would make a special bock beer for
Lent and all like the Belgian monks I
paid from the monastic that the guys
that make the Trappist beers and stuff I
heard a lot of people drink alcohol back
in a day because the water was
disgusting I was in Germany I heard that
you can live off a Guinness they called
him wild bread liquid ah liquid bread
you had the carbs of [ __ ] right so so he
say that he's altering it he's altering
the monks tradition because he will be
drinking all types of beer he does work
at a brewery all types of beer homie he
works at a brewery and at that brewery I
think he said they had like over a
hundred types of beers and like that but
he's gonna just drink all types so he
drinks about three to five beers a day
sounds like a fun challenge it's like no
defeating the purpose because you're
supposed to give up and sacrifice and go
through some kind of life he's getting
of food but if you likes beer that what
he's like that's like saying like I'm
gonna give up the [ __ ] but I must still
get [ __ ] yeah you know like exactly
it's like Steve giving up food but still
drinking monsters yeah because this
guy's beer is likes these monsters yeah
he needs to do give up everything and
just eat vegetables now that's some real
language that's like oh it's so crazy
how you can look at someone who just
know everything about them like I know
nobody does chewing tobacco I know he
has a deer head on his wall he watches
he has a deer handle he didn't hunt it
he bought it he looks like the kind of
guy that lives in Ohio but he plays
video games and you were and he likes to
drink and go to the bar a lot and eat
greasy just his flannel alone tells me
that he's a little bit more trendier
than what you're saying well I'll say no
I could tell for me I could tell by
Pendleton final his haircut hasn't been
cut in a long time I could tell that his
bathroom has that yellow film on the
grout
he hasn't cleaned that up for a while I
can tell his toothbrush bristles are
probably bent backwards that sounds like
you he's like it takes one of know one
that's why I could tell that he's
Taiwanese
the side of his bed has an indentation
from her the other side and the Sun with
the Maori name a lot of things about
sorry but I have this thing where I'm
just hate I think it's the tackiest
thing ever who decided to put license
plates up as a decoration like it
happens all the time and it's so funny
back in the day it was really cool
there's different it's pretty cool like
if you had like a bunch of travelers
come in or whatever and it's a body shop
that makes sense but to have it now I
think yeah I judgmental foes it's so
attackee like I mean like yeah it's like
you have travelers come in and you like
sneak outside and take their license
plate then that's [ __ ] sick but that
being like Lex I'm like a wall of
license plate it's like so corny it was
kind of close he put up all these metal
ones who did that this guy but these are
like actual like this is like actual art
it's a [ __ ] license buddy
Emily's are different you're right these
are completely different I remember I
went to a restaurant once where they had
a whole bunch of dollar bills everywhere
I've seen that yeah literally everywhere
yeah yeah and like sometimes people will
like sign them or like draw I like when
people draw pictures on dollar bills
like when they've take the face and make
it into a different face it's like
that's pretty sick but like I'll know
man license plates are like like that's
my favorite the rainbow line right yes
it has a rainbow that's kind of cute
though that is kind of cute Mienfoo
they're so cute I just see it and I'm
like Aloha I'm gonna chill oh I miss
Hawaii
me too see I never been I mean you see
if someone doesn't want to go Hawaii no
like there are some cool license plates
oh it does that doesn't mean I mean but
I just don't think it should be a
decoration what would be a better
decoration anything else newspapers that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah newspaper clippings yeah
a deficit murder you guys never eat that
round Table Pizza
nope yes I didn't have one around me
okay but did yours have all the
newspaper clippings and stuff like on
the table yeah on the table I remember
they had a school
right there I just realize how weird is
it that some people have probably never
seen a newspaper before like kids Oh
weird really having a population at the
liquor store and stuff still I mean but
I feel like some people probably have it
I just haven't seen a newspaper in a
long time myself
oh yeah what's it last time I saw actual
newspaper I really have it like I've
seen in like some like ad magazines and
some a thought but like an actual like
newspaper and it would be like I
recently saw one um but it was a trip
because they had this pull and then this
pole had like a whole bunch of little
slits and then they would put different
magazines and the newspapers and then
the newspaper they cut it cuz you know
how you have to like unfolded yeah yeah
yeah it's all really really really
creepy Sunday they cut it so look like a
magazine I was like oh that's [ __ ]
smart you're so cute it's been around
forever I never knew that it was like
really hipster place in Portland
I was like what the hell I've never seen
this I used to like getting newspaper
and making book covers out of the books
I wouldn't read I hated that because
then then the ink gets on your hands it
is but then it looked kind of cool then
you'll pick out the cartoon [ __ ] and
then put it there and then those
textbooks will stay brand new cuz I
never read them and I never studied what
are people gonna do now when you when
you boil some crab and you want a crab
boil and you want to lay out some
newspaper to eat we do trash bags we do
trash bags by boiling crap we cut open
the trash bag you tape it to the table
not the same it's not the same putting
out the newspaper for you bust out the
seafood yeah it was that's good that's
and then I saw another thing where some
people were like most people don't know
what you know when you would roll down
the window they don't know what that
mechanism is so many people have never
seen no go get into a car and they'll be
like what is this yeah I just saw I'm on
line two I saw someone write something
like oh my friend is a history teacher
and he brought up 9/11 and that kids in
his class were blown like their minds
were blown up oh my god real because
because what was it it was in like 2000
or anyone yeah
one so those kids are like 16 17 and in
my head they're likely functioning it
was a meme they didn't know that was
real it was photoshopped yeah like they
just thought it was 16 year olds think
that 9/11 was a meme
that's insane oh I hope that's that high
school um yeah it might be bad - yeah
but I mean like we're we're like okay
I'm trying to think of like what
happened in like I don't know 1985 that
like I didn't know about that like I
can't like I did you know but then some
people might be like oh my god yeah that
happened like if it happened before we
were born
we don't really know y2k but everyone
thought that the computers were gonna
crash in the whole role is gonna go into
epochal dad did not believe that [ __ ] at
all dude is that y2k here's our end of
the world I don't read the Bible we do
[ __ ] he just watching doesn't watch he's
like nothing's gonna happen and nothing
happened - I told you so
you're like damn it I don't see locusts
where's the locust where the where's the
Antichrist that calm down [ __ ] I was
like you know talking religious before I
know they have the confidence yeah
where's that where's it this
three-headed doggy
[Laughter]
[Music]